we are at the scene as you can see of
this disorder that broke out in the Ely
area of Cardiff last out last night
burnt out cars behind me in a bigger
cleanup operation underway but what we
can say in the last couple of minutes is
an update in regards to a crash really
which we understand at this very early
stage was the trigger to this disorder
Alan Michael who is a former MP now
local police and crime commissioner has
said this morning he was on Radio 4
saying that two young people involved in
that traffic accident died last night
there are local reports that it involved
young people on at least one scooter
and we're still really trying to piece
together exactly what happened in the
hours after that but what South Wales
police say is that they were then called
after the crash to what they described
as a large-scale disorder now you can
see here that the council workers are
cleaning up there are two burnt out cars
here a burnt out taxi uh they're on
social media appeared footage of people
throwing fireworks at police responding
broken up at Paving slabs as you can see
here on the floor there are slabs and
rocks that were broken up and we
understand Throne at police and here in
Ely this morning is a large-scale
cleaning operation just further down the
road here you can just see actually it's
still smoldering and during this
disruption that erupted last night
items were put onto essentially a
bonfire that was set up and those Flames
burnt throughout the night and a large
police presence was sent here police
helicopters who used and allowed
speakers from the helicopters were used
there's obviously it's going to be a
large scale investigation now into just
how this car crash just
just six o'clock on the outskirts of
Cardiff then triggered into many hours
of disorder and the sad news this
morning that we are hearing is that two
young people lost their lives in that
crash that is what we are understanding
it has not yet being confirmed by police
that is coming from a local police and
crime commissioner but clearly a
significant disruption a couple of burnt
out cars the cleanup operation underway
we'll get a further update from police
this morning